Hello?
Hi, my friend.
I got that kid I was talking
to you about here.
I'm gonna put him on the phone,
let you talk to him, okay?
Hello?
-Is that Frank?
-Yes.
Hiya, Frank. This is Jimmy Hoffa.
Glad to meet you.
Glad to meet you, too,
even if it's over the phone.
Our friend speaks very highly of you.
Thank you.
Only three people in the world
have one of these.
And only one of them is Irish.
I heard you paint houses.
No, no, please. No, no, wait.
Yes, I do, sir.
Where are you going?
I'm going to work.
Well, you know there's
a situation going on now, Frank.
Big business and the government,
they're trying to pull us down.
You might be demonstrating
a failure to show appreciation.
I know things they don't know I know.
You can't miss the big picture.
Sooner or later...
Get that gun out of his hand.
...everybody put here has a date
when he's gonna go.
Do you wanna be a part of this, Frank?
Would you like to be
a part of this history?
Yes, I would.
Whatever you need me to do, I'm available.
He likes to talk, don't he?